season two of Supergirl saw the show fly
over to the CW to join its fellow DC TV
shows and introduced a bunch of
brilliant new characters including Tyler
hoechlin and Superman Floriana Lima as
Maggie Sawyer and Chris Wood as monel
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to break
down through the coolness Easter eggs
and connections to comic book superhero
shows and movies that are found in
season two of Supergirl by the way I've
got an epic steeper floor / giveaway on
my Supergirl flash and arrow videos for
a chance to win any of these Funko pops
make sure you subscribe and leave a
comment about the show's Easter eggs or
season finale quick warning there are
spoilers ahead so if you want to avoid
those come back when you've caught up
with season 2 now that the series has
put a face to its Man of Steel have been
even more Superman references this
season right from the opening episode
which has named the adventures of
Supergirl in tribute to the 1940s radio
show 1950s TV series and later comic
book series The Adventures of Superman
and that popular 1940s radio show also
gave us the phrase up up and away when
Superman sawed off into the skies and
that phrase gets an airing at the end of
episode 1 when Clark and Cara said
before flying off together and again in
episode 21 when cat grant urges
Supergirl to get on with rescuing monel
and Lena Luthor speaking of cat grant
the way she reacts when she sees Clark
at Catco and the fact he says he has
some sway with her a playful nods to the
comic book series The Adventures of
Superman where the gossip columnist cat
first appeared in the late 1980s as a
romantic partner for Clark Kent and the
name of cat's new assistant mr.
Schmucker is a shout out to the first
two Superman movies with Christopher
Reeves we're test mocker was also the
name of Lex Luthor's assistant and love
interest and amusingly enough
cat grant shouts miss Tessmacher 'he's
named in exactly the same way that gene
Hackman's Luthor did in those movies in
episode 15 after chorus fired from Catco
she explains why she's upset someone
else saying Supergirl is what I can do
korra is who i am this echos Clark Kent
was to Lois Lane in the second season of
the 1990s TV series Lois and Clark which
is brilliantly fitting as not only does
this episode of Supergirl feature Dean
Cain but also Teri Hatcher who starred
as Clough and lowest in that TV show
there are more cool
Frances two iconic DC characters in the
episode welcome to earth with an
especially nicer Marshall Linda cast as
Wonder Woman when Supergirl is on fire
and puts out the flames like imitating
Carter's famous Wonder Woman spin by the
way Linda Carter who plays president
Olivia Martin on the show even gave
Melissa Benoist some tips for the scene
showing her how she did her classic
twirl
there's also another sly wink in that
episode to fans of cast as Wonder Woman
when Supergirl says Harim pressures to
have seen Air Force One and the
president replies if you think that's
cool you ought to see my other jet a
delicious reference of Wonder Woman's
invisible jet by the way the president's
name Olivia Marsden is also a little hat
tip to Olive Byrne one of the
inspirations behind Wonder Woman and to
Wonder Woman's creator William move from
Austin oh and the president's hairstyle
in episode 17 and 21 is a little
throwback to Lynda Carter's look of
Diana Prince in her 70s TV series
macabre ups got to suit up this season
as Jimmy Olsen took on the mantle of The
Guardian a DC character who first
appeared in issue 7 of star-spangled
comics when a cop called Jim Harper
became a vigilante and during guardians
first appearance in episode 6 there's a
nod to his characters comic book origins
thanks to wins ban which has the words
star-spangled delivery company
emblazoned on it along with the year
1941 which is when the first issue of
star-spangled comics was published when
the number 204 on the van is a reference
to the last issue published in the
retitled star-spangled series plus in
the following episode guardian catches a
thief who's just dropped a store called
newsboy which is a shout-out to the
newsboy legion a boy gang who appeared
alongside Guardian in the comics the
title of the mid-season premiere
Supergirl lives as a shout-out to the
episodes director Kevin Smith and his
script for the abandoned 1990s movie
Superman live which was going to be
directed by Tim Burton and star Nick
Cage as Superman and there's another
sneaky reference to that cancelled film
when one else held Supergirl that the
alien Joe Gunn wrath is cooking up Sun a
gariand snow beast when Kevin Smith was
developing the Superman live script
producer Jon Peters insisted there
should be a scene where Superman battles
a giant spider and the planned name for
that spider was a Santa garyun snow
beast season two's also brought
nice sprinkling of Batman references in
the fortress of solitude
just before Supergirl sets the atomic
cauldron to blow up herself and mr. mixi
spit lick she tells the
fifth-dimensional imp that she's had
enough of his games and as you want to
get nuts let's get nuts
that line is straight from Tim Burton's
1989 Batman movie and was said by
Michael Keaton's Bruce Wayne as he flew
into a rage with the Joker and in
episode 20 city of lost children there's
a humorous nod the Caped Crusader and
the Man of Steel brought relationship in
both the comics and the movie Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice when James
laments that people he tries to help her
skirt by his guardian outfit people see
this big guy in a scary mask and they
run away just like Clark's friends as
James to which Winn replies I feel like
they're more frenemies of course there
are tens more Easter eggs and references
in the show but what were your favorites
and what did you think of the season
finale and what are you looking forward
to seeing in season 3 be sure to leave a
comment and subscribe for a chance to
win one of these cool Funko pops which
I'm giving away on this Supergirl video
and on my upcoming flash season 3 and
arrow season 5 Easter egg videos if you
enjoyed this video do please like and
share it and check out more of my Easter
egg and DC videos by clicking or tapping
the screen here thanks for watching and
see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers